le prix du pain est assez éloignée du
prix de ces matières premières claire
gaudin nous dit je trouve dommage que
monsieur capelette ne reçoivent que 18
cents par pain pour son blé comment les
épiciers justifie t'il un prix de plus
de 4 dollars pour d'abord il faut savoir
que monsieur capelette comme ses
confrères n'a pas d' influence sur le
prime un pro du tannat contrôle jamais
les règles du marché est on est on est
comme on dit les preneurs de prix on
prend le pari que le marché dicte d'un
code du blé le bi et trans g sur les
marchés publics à chicago alors ce qui
sort du champ pour un pain et se vend 18
ou 20 cents
il faut d'abord le transformer en farine
ça c'est le travail des moulins à la
sortie ça ne ressemble pas encore à du
pain mais ça vaut déjà 80 cents selon
jean françois ouellette et je suis
professeur à hec montréal là où la
valeur est vraiment ajouté c'est quand
on transforme cette farine en pin avec
d'autres ingrédients le fameux boulanger
qui lui va produire le prêt pour payer
ses employés payés son infrastructure
ces fausses en électricité son loyer et
revendre son fameux pain environ 2
dollars 40 à un détaillant qui lui voulu
revendre à toi dollars 60 à 4 $ tout
dépendant de la présence de graines de
lin biologique ou pas la plus grande
marge est toujours celle prise par le
détail à depuis le début des années 2000
au canada le prix du pain a été
multiplié par deux dans certains cas un
vin 2015
larose était inexplicable on sait
pourquoi aujourd'hui
alors le cartel du pain un cartel au
niveau des grossistes qui un cartel au
niveau des détaillants et au delà des
cartes cadeau de 25 $ qui en faisait la
demande
le prix du pain est resté à peu près au
même niveau
[Musique]